l'information peut être un facteur de
paix c'est le credo qu'on partage depuis
20 ans dans une fondation la fondation
hirondelle que je préside
c'est le credo que j'aimerais beaucoup
partager avec vous ce soir
la fondation hirondelle ce sont une
poignée de journalistes qui ont couvert
à l'époque le génocide du rwanda
massacre abominable massacre provoquée
entre autres par une information
manipuler à travers la radio mille
collines qui appelait les gens des
voisins qui vivaient en harmonie plus ou
moins à se massacrer ses journalistes se
sont dit plus jamais ça
si l'information peut être un facteur de
haine
il peut aussi être un facteur de paix
mais pas n'importe quelle information
l'information indépendante
la formation neutre la formation
vérifier la formation honnête ce type
d'information qui permet aux citoyens de
se faire une opinion et d'être vraiment
un citoyen ce type d'information est
capitale pour une société est capital
parce qu'il permet la construction
démocratique de la société et comment je
sais comment c'est heureusement en
suisse sans démocratie il n'ya pas de
développement économique harmonieux pour
tous voyez
l'information est capitale alors ces
journalistes depuis 20 ans ont essaimé
ont ouvert des radios des médias des
studios de production des lignes de du
web aussi ça commençait au rwanda
proches plutôt du côté du zaïre ex zaïre
avec radio agatha chien puis il ya eu le
kosovo le congo le liberia le timor la
tunisie aujourd'hui le mali la fondation
hirondelle à chaque jour des dizaines de
millions d'auditeurs et de lecteurs
on le sait peut-être passé en suisse
c'est un des plus grands médias de
suisse la fondation hirondelle est
aujourd'hui aussi réclamé un peu de
partout par l'onu par l'union européenne
par la coopération suisse évidemment on
lui demande de réfléchir un projet en
syrie bien sûr on lui demande de
réfléchir un projet en libye ce qu'on
est en train de faire en ukraine en
ukraine on vient d'ouvrir et de lancer
une première plateforme site d'info web
en ligne en trois langues en français en
anglais et en ne craignant pas besoin de
vous dire à quel point le monde est
traversé de conflits de haine souvent
provoquées par des amalgames par les a
priori par le fait qu'on ne se parle pas
nous en suisse on sait qu'on peut se
parler on sait que la corne la
construction démocratique bien ces
débats qu'on fait régulièrement les gens
ne sont pas d'accord
les gens peuvent être assez vifs dans
les débats mais finalement l'opinion se
fait et c'est ça l'idée de la fondation
hirondelle et c'est ça c'est peut-être
pas non plus tout à fait étonnant que
cette fondation était été créée par des
journalistes suisses je suis moi
personnellement très admirative du
système que nos ancêtres ont réussi à
mettre en place je crois que c'est un
modèle pour beaucoup et c'est ce modèle
qui est qu'on essaye de transporter
depuis 21 ans
ce credo ne va pas tout à fait de soi on
voit très bien dans les zones de
conflits l'utilité d'une aide
alimentaire d'une aide économique d'une
aide médicale d'une aide d'urgence
d'urgence la formation c'est plus
volatile
c'est plus difficile à expliquer pour ça
que je suis là ce soir
j'espère pouvoir faire passer le message
une société une société se construit sur
des bases solides bases économiques
masse politiques institutions
l'information est un des piliers
essentiels
nous y croyons nous y croyons vraiment
très fortement
et la fondation hirondelle un point
acquis en 20 ans une expérience unique
unique au monde je ne suis pas la seule
je ne suis pas seul à le dire je préside
la fondation je n'ai pas créé je rends
hommage à ces journalistes qui l'ont
créé qu'ils ont fait et qui travaillent
tous les jours nous sommes reconnus par
l'onu par l'union européenne par aussi
la suisse didier burkhalter notre
ministre des affaires étrangères l'an
dernier au conseil des états a rendu
hommage au travail de la fondation
parlant précisément d'expérience
reconnue internationalement et d'un
travail qui mérite qu'on parle de lui je
voulais juste vous donner un exemple de
ce que ce qu'on fait dans un des pays de
ce la centrafrique la centrafrique c'est
un exemple du mal-développement un pays
immensément scandaleusement riche et en
richesses naturelles en sous sol et puis
évidemment scandaleusement pauvre un
pays à terre un pays où tous tes les
institutions de la peine à tenir en
place et dans ce pays nous sommes là
depuis vingt ans la radio la plus
écoutée d'ailleurs en général nous
sommes les médias les plus écoutées dans
les pays où nous sommes et je voulais
vous rendre hommage justement à ces
journalistes toujours des journalistes
locaux ont toujours toujours nous
travaillons toujours avec les
journalistes locaux qui sont évidemment
dont les programmes sont surveillés nous
en voyons depuis lausanne des formateurs
c'est comme ça que nous travaillons dans
les langues des pays est évidemment
aussi en anglais en français chez nous
les journalistes n'ont pas de religion
ils sont simplement journalistes ils
n'ont pas d'opinion ils sont
journalistes ils n'ont pas d'ethnie ils
sont journalistes au kosovo en pleine
guerre du kosovo il y avait à la radio
blu sky de la fondation hirondelle des
journalistes d'origine kosovare
albanaise qui travaille en tout à fait
belle harmonie au service de
l'information
je vous demande trois minutes
d'attention pour vous montrer un extrait
d'un film qu'on a tourné
sur la fondation est grande elle a bondi
en décembre 2013 l'onu évoque un bilan
d'au moins 3000 morts et un million de
déplacés les forces françaises de
l'opération 100 garris s'interpose entre
milices
a radio des quais loca journalistes
chrétiens et musulmans se côtoient
ils sont soumis aux mêmes menaces un
point de repère fiable
dans le cas où des guerres civiles face
aux récents affrontements meurtriers
entre milices la radio tient le cap
celui d'une information factuelle mais
les risques sont quotidiens mais quand
on veut avec un peu par en compte les
dispositions en appel pour que les
autres aussi pour voir un peu ce que
nous pouvons venir au parc dont ils
prennent aussi des dispositions injustes
sont pour nous un cul et pour nous
protéger nous faciliter le train donc on
évolue comme ça où sera mesure quoi donc
on se on se renseigne on cherche à
savoir est ce qu'on peut rentrer on peut
pas rentrer mais si on te parenthèse
combat en véhicule est ce qu on y va en
taxi est ce que est ce que l'enfant
prend toutes les dispositions avant nous
serons donc c'est toujours présent à
l'esprit quoi l'esprit de la sécurité et
donc c'est pas facile quoi c'est
beaucoup plus il
parce que tout n'est pas musulman là
vous pouvez librement au km5 vous ne
pouvez pas traversé le coût de 25
passé soit dans mouture 1
avec une arme bien couteau
samuel est originaire des quartiers
chrétiens
il est en reportage côté musulman grâce
sans doute à l'ouverture sous bonne
garde du dialogue entre chrétiens et
musulmans
sous cette tente la réconciliation est
peut-être en othe la population du coa
de la population des traces de manson
est autre chose que la que la paix et la
paix véritable passe que dans tout ce
qui s'est passé
rien c'est à jusqu'aujourd'hui le 3ème
arrondissement a subi un relooking
ce que demande la population ce n'est
que la paix des appels qui ouvriront le
prochain journal la rédaction et
centrafricaine des formateurs venus de
lausanne vienne mesurer avec les
journalistes
le poids des mots
aujourd'hui radio ndeke luka est la plus
écoutée du pays
accepter d'être journaliste aujourd'hui
indiqué luca c'est se sacrifier
considère j'y vais avec le risque du
lycée mabhouh voilà mais on continue de
le faire
on enrage un recul etc
vous avez entendu les gens qui disent ce
que nous voulons c'est la paix je crois
que si on posait la question à la
plupart des syriens des ukrainiens des
gens qui vivent dans des situations de
crise de guerre
la plupart dire est ce que l'on veut
c'est la paix et c'est ce message qu'on
essaie de passer à travers cette
information vérifiée à travers aussi le
dialogue dans chaque média dans chaque
radio nous avons les débats et ça me
débats par exemple au mali pays au bord
de la guerre civile pays traversé par
des conflits musulmans éthiques
nous avons un format quotidien
extrêmement suivi qui s'appelle le grand
débat on y débat par exemple des
violences intercommunautaires voilà les
thèmes la radicalisation les compromis
qui sont politiques
nous avons réussi à mettre sur le même
banc sur le même table de à la radio
nous avons réussi à mettre en face en
reste présentant de la rébellion de des
touareg un représentant des groupes
d'armes d'autodéfense et demi et en
présentant du ministère de la
réconciliation
encore une fois en suisse on connaissait
on sait ça on connaît le dialogue et la
puissance du dialogue
c'est ça que nous faisons dans tous nos
médias nous sommes sur le web
nous sommes nous avons des maisons de
production et nous avons aussi des
radios partout l'information peut être
un facteur de paix c'est vraiment le
credo qu'aujourd'hui je voulais partager
avec vous merci de votre attention